we have a big development in the
diplomatic fallout from russia's
invasion of ukraine two nordic countries
finland and sweden have announced plans
to join nato mts tayab is in finland mts
good morning
hey good morning well russia is calling
this move a grave mistake as finland
moves to join nato a decision which
would see nato's land border with russia
more than double in size
[Music]
we have today a historic day
and with that the finnish president and
prime minister announced the nordic
nation's intention to join nato ditching
decades of neutrality towards russia the
nuclear threat from russia is of course
a concern
does joining nato make finland more
vulnerable to that threat the nuclear
threat it's very serious i think that
within nato
actually it gives us security when it
comes to nuclear because nato also have
nuclear
threat nuclear weapons
russia's war and ukraine triggered
finland's decision to join the military
alliance but a massive shift in public
opinion here made it politically
possible
around 20 percent of finns supported
joining nato before the war in ukraine
now 75 percent due
this swimming center in the heart of
helsinki doubles as a nuclear bomb
shelter one of over 5 000 around the
capital city a legacy of soviet russia's
invasion here in the 1940s says tomy
rask with the civil defense department
the
last wars that finland had were quite a
few decades ago 1945 and you still think
about it
the probability is
it's not a zero
it still is some kind of probability
in helsinki this morning senate minority
leader mitch mcconnell welcomed finnish
leaders to nato
frankly their participation strengthens
the alliance significantly
now the speed with which finland and
indeed sweden are moving to join nato is
frankly unprecedented but the leaders of
both countries say they feel they have
little choice but to join the military
alliance nate
mts tayab in finland thank you